hello there internet
i'm john oliver host of last week
tonight we are off this week but i'm
coming straight to youtube exclusively
to say smash that like button hit
subscribe click that notification bell
hit the little x on your browser close
your laptop and go outside because this
whole video is about
cereal i'm aware that there is a lot
going on in the world right now but
instead of focusing on
any of that i'd like to raise a subject
that is near and dear to my heart and
that is
there simply aren't enough cereals and
to be clear i don't mean in a
food shortage sort of way like we're
running out of cereal and
as a result people are starving although
that might be the case i don't actually
know i just mean
that there aren't enough new cereals
anymore you might say
that's a minor gripe but think about it
we haven't had an exciting new cereal
in what feels like a hundred years
remember how thrilling
serial news used to be remember when
trix tried to unite a divided country by
introducing wild berry blue
a new fruit shape that wasn't just red
or blue but both
of course you do it was a controversial
as it was delicious and it represented
what cereal could be at its best
innovative inexplicable
transformative remember when a
presumably fatal factory error resulted
in a cereal that was 100
crunchy fruit berries remember reese's
puffs
when that first came out no one even
knew if that was legal it was candy
for breakfast the point is when was the
last time
cereal news penetrated the mainstream
since then i'll tell you
it hasn't in fact in the last 10
years
there has been exactly one good serial
commercial and is this one
which is 30 seconds of sheer perfection
no way
no really i think i could dunk on you
maybe
but i bet i love kellogg's frosted
flakes more than you
you are funny that's the truth dolly
come on buddy my picture's on the box
tie breaker who's got the deeper voice
i win i win i win tony oh you're cute
when you're wrong and i still love these
more than you
no way same time tomorrow tony yeah see
you then buddy
all right love you love you more
excellent
that is start to finish a perfect serial
commercial because it begins
with shaquille o'neal telling tony the
tiger no way with absolutely
zero additional context right off the
bat an incredible introduction to any
piece of art and it ends with him
telling somebody the tiger i love you in
just half a minute
it established a world in which tony the
tiger exists has a
handsomely decorated home office
including a custom tony nameplate
apparently video chats shaquille o'neal
every single morning for breakfast
and that they love each other that is a
more richly
detailed cinematic universe than what
marvel has made in
13 years it is genuinely hard to
decide no i'm
still talking about the commercial it's
genuinely hard to decide
what my favorite part is up to and
including the fact that on youtube it's
titled
mission tiger tit for tat look
i can't say that that commercial
inspired me to buy frosted flakes why
would it after all
they are human scabs that have been
non-consensually dredged through
powdered sugar they're a potpourri
mistake
that simply never got corrected it's a
trash cereal but
it is still far and away the best thing
to happen to cereal
in decades because cereals aren't even
trying look at
cheerios their official twitter account
has fully submitted
to the worst toothless impulses that
dominate positivity twitter
they deliver empty nonsense like good
morning
today is yours what
and families make the good go round what
the are you talking about your oat
hoops
no one looks to cheerios for positivity
especially when you consider the fact
that when cheerios asked for acts of
goodness to share
they didn't retweet any examples you
worthless
impotent empty suit of a cereal brand
you know what
i'm gonna issue you a one-time challenge
i will donate 25
000 to the charity of cheerios choice
if they simply use their official
account to tweet you
i'll do it and what's more i will double
it if they target the twitter account
of an actual non-famous random user and
do it but the larger point here is
cereal is in a rut and don't tell me
there is not room to innovate here
how about making an existing cereal blue
making
oops or marshmallows make
gushers a cereal i don't care
those are just three hit ideas off the
top of my head and i'm not even a serial
scientist
why is there a cereal where the pieces
look like tiny little men
think about it make the shapes little
men with marshmallow dogs
so it would be a serial way you pretend
to be a giant while eating it listen to
me
and think about that uh what about
nighttime cereal what do i mean by that
i don't know you the market is
hungry for fresh ideas here's another
one
what about a cereal where the pieces
look exactly like legos and you can eat
them and they're delicious i know what
some of the parents are thinking they're
thinking
this is a great idea and they're
absolutely right
what about a mystery box cereal there's
a big question mark
on that box and every single cereal is
different holy
that is such a good idea
why isn't there a cereal for goth kids
seriously why not the marketing for
almost every cereal seems to be
sports centric there's often a chase or
some heist
involved or the implication that cereal
is essential for before
and after doing sports there has never
once
been a single cereal marketed directly
and solely to soft
sad sixth graders who feel lonely even
when they're surrounded by people and
that
is frankly unforgivable there should be
a cereal for kids
who won't really have friends until
college and someone should make it for
them
and before one of you comments what
about count chocula
you goth kids don't like
chocolate they hate it goodbye
i am so desperate to see something new
and challenging in the cereal
marketplace
that i'm here by offering one of our
many
living and breathing mascots to whatever
cereal company
actually makes something that i deem
fresh and provocative you want the we
got him tiger
you got him you want mr nutta butter
he's yours
you want the vaccine cicada to promote
your new cereal that's a very weird
request and i already like the way that
this is headed the point is
any of these things are yours if you
elevate the serial game
for the common good is this what america
needs right now
no is it what it wants yes
yes it is and if you hold up your end
maybe just maybe
we can heal this nation a little bit i'm
john oliver
this has been youtube smash that like
button
we'll be back june 6th goodbye
you